JARED COHEN: I'm really
delighted to be here
with a colleague and dear friend
of mine, Alec Ross, author
of the New York Times bestseller
"Industries of the Future."
I would say you should
go out and buy it,
which you should, but all of you
have free copies, which means,
go out and buy copies for
all your friends and family.
It's really an
extraordinary book.
It covers everything
from robotics
to genomics, to geopolitics,
to how to be a good parent.
And Alec has really
done incredible job
traversing the globe,
trying to understand
what the next wave of
globalization looks
like, really across a
diverse array of sectors.
Before we get into
this, I wanted
to share a little bit
about Alec's background,
because we've known each
other for quite some time.
We've gotten into some
mischief together.
We've been in and our of
trouble over the course
of the last decade.
We had a chance to work together
for Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton, possibly
soon to be President
Clinton, the second one.
And Alec was Hillary's
first ever senior advisor
for innovation.
And it was a position
that she created for him.
And what was more amazing
about it is Alec had run a tech
policy and innovation for
the Obama '08 campaign,
and was the sole Obama
person who managed to land
in the State Department.
I think we all
remember that tension
that existed between the Hillary
Clinton camp and the Obama
camp.
And he made innovation a part
of American foreign policy
in a way that really
didn't exist before.
So I want to start by
thanking you for your service
to the country, but also thank
you for joining us today.
This book is as much about
the industries of the future
as it is an individual
sitting next to me
who has spent his
entire life trying
to answer a fundamental question
about what's happening next.
And I want to start
with the first sentence
of the book, which
is, "it's 3:00 AM,
and I'm mopping up
whiskey smelling puke
after a country music concert
in Charleston, West Virginia."
And this is a book about
industries of the future,
so take us from mopping
up puke in West Virginia
to the person who
ended up writing
a book about what the next wave
of globalization looks like.
ALEC ROSS: Well, thank you,
Jared for that introduction,
and thank you all for
coming out this afternoon.
So it's 3 o'clock
in the morning.
I'm mopping up
whiskey smelling puke
after a country music concert
in Charleston, West Virginia.
Why was I doing that?
Well, when I was in college,
having grown up a public school
kid in West Virginia,
while most of my classmates
at my fancy college were
off doing unpaid internships
at investment banks, or law
firms, or tech companies,
or their parents had gotten
them apartments in Washington
DC so they could be
interns in Congress,
I had to actually make
money when I was in college.
And so what that meant
for me going home
was the jobs that I had
were working on a beer truck
and working as a
midnight janitor.
And so growing up
in West Virginia,
I thought that my reality was
like everybody's reality, which
is, from an economic
standpoint, what you're actually
trying to do is just manage
decline as best you can.
And so it wasn't until
I left West Virginia
and I entered the
work world, and I
was very blessed and privileged
to get to spend a couple
decades as an entrepreneur,
in politics, in government,
as an author, till I fully
understood that globalization
was not about managing
dissent, that, point
in fact, globalization was
overwhelmingly positive.
But in the community
that I grew up in,
it was not entirely positive.
And so was the process
of writing the book,
the reason why I open
up with that story
is I try to give a balanced
perspective on a view
into the future.
Most people who write
books about the future
write either utopian
books or dystopian books.
It's either, we're
going to live to be
150 years old, happy,
healthy, wealthy,
wanting for nothing,
nothing but abundance.
Or it's written from the
fetal position, sort of eyes
closed, fists clenched, usually
shaking a fist at you guys.
But I think the reality is
much more up the middle,
and net optimistic.
I think that tomorrow
will be better than today.
But in examining the
industries of the future,
it was important for
me from the very outset
to do some framing just so
that it would be understood
that it was viewed through the
eyes of a public school kid
from West Virginia,
who put himself
through college by working
as a midnight janitor,
as opposed to from a position
of lifelong privilege.
JARED COHEN: So
I want to ask you
one question about your time
at the State Department.
Before I do that,
Sam's giving me
a look, because I realize I
forgot to introduce myself.
Jared Cohen, president
of Jigsaw alphabet,
and advisor to Eric
Schmidt as well.
ALEC ROSS: I bet they
all know who you are.
I'm happy to speak at great
length about who you are.
JARED COHEN: No, no.
Let's go back to you.
So you went to the
State Department.
You had never met
Hillary Clinton
before you started
working for her.
Is that correct?
ALEC ROSS: I had
actually met her before.
JARED COHEN: What
was the context.
ALEC ROSS: The context
was my social enterprise
had done some work in
partnership with her office,
but we were not close.
JARED COHEN: And
she's a politician.
They don't remember anything.
ALEC ROSS: Yeah, she
shakes lots of hands.
JARED COHEN: So what is
the first conversation
about innovation
with her look like?
She's just lost an election.
It looked like she was
heading to retirement.
She gets resurrected
as Secretary of State,
and then you appear.
And you have a conversation
about innovation.
What does that look like?
ALEC ROSS: It was a fairly
remarkable conversation.
I mean, I was on the
presidential transition team,
and I was busy trying to
figure out which fancy job I
was going to take.
You know, the White
House, or Chief of Staff
of this, or doing that.
And I was summoned to
see Hillary Clinton.
And I was like, why
does she want to see me?
Does she want to yell at me?
Because I had run technology and
media policy for the campaign
to beat her.
And she sat me down,
and she said, Alec,
I thought I was going
to be president.
And she said, and I have lots
of very capable people, who
I know and like, who
were going to fill up
the executive ranks of the
politically appointed offices
across the federal government.
She's like, now I need to fit
them all into one department,
into the State Department.
She goes, but I need
to make one exception.
She goes, I need one
of you internet people.
One of you innovation people.
She said, I think the promise
and peril of the 21st century
is no longer contained by vast
distances or national borders.
And I think the internet is
going to be a big part of that.
Now, I should say at
this point that I did not
set up her emails.
so--
[LAUGHTER]
I did not.
So for those of
you in this room,
I would think that most
of you could probably
set up homebrewed servers in
basements, but for those few
of you who work at Google
who can't, if you are here
at this session to learn
how to do that, this
is the wrong session.
That was another guy.
JARED COHEN: Who
just got immunity.
ALEC ROSS: He did
just get immunity.
He actually applied
to me for a job,
and actually didn't get a job.
But we'll leave that aside.
The point being is that
she recognized early.
She saw in her own
campaign how the internet
was something that
significantly impacted
her campaign for the worse.
She ran a good 20th
century campaign.
Senator Obama ran a good
21st century campaign.
And so her theory becoming
Secretary of State
was that information
networks would impact
the conduct of diplomacy.
And it proved to be right,
for better, for worse,
from WikiLeaks on, what
was thought, at the time,
to be the negative
side, to programs we
built on the positive science.
So basically, her theory,
which Jared and I and a woman
named Anne Marie
Slaughter then built out
some intellectual
architecture below,
was that the
internet would change
the traditional
relationships in diplomacy
beyond the formal architecture
of 196 sovereign nation states.
JARED COHEN: And
it's worth adding
that if we actually reflect
back, this was not so obvious
back then.
To all of you, it would have
been obvious, but to the stodgy
halls of government, back
then, you more of less
got laughed out of the room
for talking about the internet
or technology in
any public sector
context that wasn't the FCC.
Let's turn to your book.
One of the things that's
interesting about your book
is you move beyond the jargon
of today, where people talk
so much about AI, and
disruption, and innovation,
and machine learning, that
these words and terms,
they're used and overused,
in context, out of context--
ALEC ROSS: I don't know
what they mean anymore.
JARED COHEN: Essentially
they've lost their meaning.
You argue in the book
that globalization
is an ongoing process.
It never finishes.
And you spend a lot
of time focusing less
on the jargon of today, and
where this is all going.
What is the next wave of
globalization that excites you?
And where are we
today in the process?
ALEC ROSS: The next
wave of globalization
that most excites
me is-- I think
that a substantial number
of today's frontier markets
will become
tomorrow's developing
markets, and a substantial
number of today's developing
markets will be tomorrow's
developed markets.
So the real story, if
you just do the math,
the great story of globalization
in the last 25 years
is the story of India and China.
Nearly a billion, billion with
a B, nearly a billion people
migrated out of poverty into
the working and middle classes
from China and India.
And so I think
that that is really
the big story of the last
stage of globalization.
But I think what will be
the story of the next stage
of globalization are markets
that we think of as largely
inaccessible, suddenly
becoming accessible.
And I think that
this is going to be
a byproduct in part of the
combination of hardware
and software innovation.
And so if I can
take a minute or two
to describe one of this
weirder predictions of mine
from the book, but which I--
God's honest truth-- I believe
is going to be true.
So right now, there's
some very difficult access
to markets like, Papua
New Guinea, and Indonesia.
And, Jared, I hope you and I
travel to Papua New Guinea.
JARED COHEN: I would love to.
ALEC ROSS: Yes, before
it gets overrun by guys
in white shirts and red ties.
Papua New Guinea is largely
inaccessible for most
businesses right now, because
they speak over 800 languages.
It might seem like a ridiculous
reason for barrier to entry,
but it's actually why people
have a very hard time doing
business there.
Similarly, Indonesia.
There are enough people
in Jakarta and Bali
who speak English or French
that you can do business
in Jakarta and
Bali, but there are
over 1,100 islands and over
700 of other languages spoken.
So the vast majority of
Indonesia, for example,
is largely inaccessible.
And so what I
believe is that there
will be a device, that if you
travel to Papua New Guinea,
and somebody is speaking
one of those 800 languages,
there will be an earpiece
that you can put in your ear,
and as someone is speaking
to you in whatever language,
at the speed of sound, the
voice that you hear in your ear
will be the language
that you want to hear.
And it won't be Siri's voice.
It will measure the
frequency, wavelength,
and sound intensity, and
other properties of the voice,
and translate the voice that
you are hearing in your ear,
very closely
approximating the speaker.
And so I think that that kind
of thing, like literally being
able to pop
something in your ear
and be able to speak to
anybody in any language
is going to do more to unleash
the next wave of globalization
than anything else.
JARED COHEN: On
the device thing,
I can't resist the urge to ask,
if there's a friend of mine
that I think has a
particularly soothing voice
or an endearing voice,
can I have that voice?
Or am I stuck with
some version of my own?
ALEC ROSS: So for those of
you who don't know Jared,
this is a characteristically
Jared question.
Of course, Jared.
JARED COHEN: Can you do
your mother-in-law, or no?
ALEC ROSS: I'm sure you can
do an Australian accent.
JARED COHEN: Can
you combine them?
Could I do Australian
accent on Tuesday, ,
mother-in-law on Thursday,
best friend on Friday?
ALEC ROSS: You know, given
the product hasn't actually
been invented yet,
when I invent it,
I'll be sure to keep these
design features in mind.
JARED COHEN: And it is fun to
speculate about the future.
The best part is,
if you're right,
everyone thinks you're a genius.
If you speculate far enough into
the future, and you're wrong,
nobody remembers,
and you can deny it.
ALEC ROSS: What I
did in this book,
I tried to keep
things bounded 20
years at the outermost limit.
Because beyond that,
it gets a little silly.
And I also think
that things are going
to change rather substantially
over the next 20 years.
JARED COHEN: So I want to ask
you a little bit about norms.
Because obviously, this
group understands technology
very well, probably better
than any other groups
that you've spoken to while
you've been on book tour.
But norms matter a lot.
And you have a really
interesting couple chapters
where you touch on robotics.
And one of the
things you observe
is it seems that in the
US, the notion of robotics
is scary to the general
populace and evokes images
of Terminator.
And maybe that's because
"Terminator 2" was
a very popular American movie.
But then you go to
Japan, and you spend time
with robotics companies there,
and it's wildly embraced.
Talk about what is it
about culture in Japan
and elsewhere that
leads people to have
a totally different
interpretation of what
is, in fact, the
same technology.
ALEC ROSS: It's
really interesting.
So in Western societies,
Western religions,
our mythology, our culture,
tells us, reinforces the idea
that we ought to guard
against animating,
bringing to life that
which perhaps we ought not.
So from Icarus's waxed
wings to Frankenstein,
we're continually warned in
our mythology, in our culture,
in our fiction,
against such things.
By contrast, in Japan, for
example, 80% of Japanese people
practice Shinto, the
religion of Shinto.
In Shinto, they
believe in animism,
which holds that objects,
like humans, have souls.
And so one of the, I think,
quite interesting innovations
that I described that's
happening right now
is the move towards elder
care robots in Japan.
JARED COHEN: How many
of you have heard?
Raise your hand.
How many of you have heard of
elder care robots in Japan?
The highest penetration
in any audience
of people that
have heard of that.
ALEC ROSS: I was about
to say, that's bananas.
I must be at Google.
For the 40% of you who
have not heard of this,
Japan has the world's
longest living citizens.
I think it's 83 for
women, 79 for men.
And they are growing
older because
of relatively
restrictive immigration
policies and low birth rates.
There are not enough
grandchildren to take
care of grandparents.
And so Honda and Toyota, yes,
the auto makers, as well as
some startups, are looking
at literally creating--
they are creating home care
robots which do everything
from lift the
grandparents out of bed
to entertain them with violin
playing and other such things.
But what's interesting
to me is the degree
to which culture is
deterministic in terms
of the creation of these robots
and the degree to which people
are and are not comfortable
with the technology.
And so I think
that this is going
to effect-- when you look at
the 196 country chess board,
if you think of robots as being
one of the industries that
is consequential
today, but which
will be substantially more
consequential tomorrow,
I think a lot of it is going to
come from East Asian societies,
in part because they don't have
the cultural package that we
do in the West.
JARED COHEN: So I want to
stay on this theme of norms,
because I think it's something
that we at Google and Alphabet
and more broadly could probably
spend a little bit more time
thinking about.
And nuanced differences
between robotics
evoking fears of
terminator in the West
and being wildly embraced
in the East, that's
subtle compared to some of
the more complex normative
challenges.
So one of the things you
talk a lot about in your book
is the commercialization of
genomics and life sciences
more broadly.
When we talk about
these things, we
talk as if there is one of
the jurisdiction on Earth.
And it makes all that
the ethical conversations
and debates that we have
miss the larger point, which
is there's 196 different
jurisdictions on Earth.
And they range from North
Korea to the United States
and everything in between.
So you have a situation
where countries
have different sets of values,
and ethics, and ambitions,
and aspirations, and so let's
take a very controversial
debate that we're
all familiar with,
which is the process
of editing genes
to improve an unborn child.
There are lots of regulations
in the United States,
for instance, that will protect
against the productization
of babies.
But what happens when
some entrepreneur decides,
OK, I can't do this
in China, but Qatar
will let me build a
multi-billion dollar
company that does gene editing
to get the right eye color,
or gene editing to
get the right height?
How do you handle that kind
of an ethical asymmetry?
And who ends up winning
in that situation?
Is it the
jurisdictions that have
the right ethical
standards, if you can answer
the question of who's right?
Or is it the
jurisdictions that have
a very lax and irresponsible
attitude about this?
ALEC ROSS: So let's
unpack that a little bit.
So for context, the norms that
exist in terms of governance
on the internet,
exist dating back
to a period when nobody was
really paying attention.
So you know I'm sure
most of this audience
is familiar with the
multi-stakeholder model
for internet governance
that is inclusive
of the private sector,
government, academia,
civil society, and
it's international,
though the United
States has a pretty
heavy thumb on the scale on
policy issues of consequence.
To be able to create the
governance model, which
in turn dominates the norms
setting for the internet,
it would be impossible to
reconstitute that today.
They were only able
to do it at the time
because there was insufficient
attention given to the issue,
and there was
remarkable asymmetry
in terms of the
capability, where
the capabilities were largely
domiciled in the United States.
So the United States got
to dominate the process
for establishing
governance of the internet
and the subsequent
norms setting.
Now I think that for the
industries of the future,
and let's stick to the
commercialization of genomics,
which you brought up,
everybody has two eyes open.
And so the idea that the
rules and regulations that
are set in the United
States and the norms,
that which is considered to
be acceptable or unacceptable
independent of
regulation and statute,
the idea that our country,
which constitutes fewer than 5%
of the globe's
population, is going
to be able to dictate what the
95% of the rest of the world
thinks, does, and
accepts, is naive.
Especially, since there
are other states out there,
like China, for example,
which are investing very, very
aggressively in the
space, so that they
can be the headquarters to
the Googles of genomics.
The world's last
trillion dollar industry
was created out
of computer code.
The world's next
trillion dollar industry
is going to be created
out of genetic code.
And it is an open
question where the HQs
will be for the trillion
dollar industry of the future.
And so getting back to
this question of norms,
what I believe is going to
happen is that if the United
States significantly regulates
what can and cannot be done
with gene editing,
then we will see,
in the same way in which
Switzerland created
a permissionless environment
for decades in banking,
I think that we will see the
equivalent of what Switzerland
was to banking will
be-- you said Qatar--
will be any of 10 or 12 states
around the globe for genomics.
So that an expectant
mother, who is
newly in her second
trimester, who do
has seen that there
is a mutation,
a specific protein is
misfiring on a gene
and she wants it fixed,
but it countervails
the laws in the United States,
then she'll get on a plane,
and she will fly to whatever
country does allow it.
And so what I think is that is
interesting is that I do think
that, ultimately, these
countries-- these companies
that all are
commercializing genomics
will set up in the
most lax environment.
From a regulatory
standpoint, we already
see within the
life sciences lots
of companies moving
their headquarters abroad
for tax purposes.
So, bluntly, there's already
a culture within the field
of saying, you know what?
We don't have to be
an American company.
And then, as we all know, they
can create corporate vehicles,
even if they do have
most of their employees
in the United States.
They'll create different
corporate vehicles
and structures to allow
them to end up doing
whatever they want abroad.
So I think that
government actually
has significantly
limited power to curtail
innovation and privatization
in this space, norms be damned.
Because somebody
somewhere will create
an environment that allows
people to you whatever
you want.
JARED COHEN: And what's the
regulatory reaction to that?
You have a bunch of
companies out there
that are difficult to
regulate, and maybe they're
doing something
disruptive, but they're
difficult to regulate
because of the jurisdictions
that they're headquartered in.
Is there a risk that the
companies that are doing it
right, that are operating in
stricter jurisdictions end up
getting the wrath of government,
because they can be scrutinized
whereas some of
the others can't?
ALEC ROSS: I mean,
so yes, but let's
also back up a little bit.
Back up.
And let's actually
ask the question--
should parents be able to
do gene edit so that instead
of having a son who's projected
to be between 5'5 and 5'7, they
want to add inches.
They want them to be
between 6'2 and 6'4.
They want to not just
repair damaged DNA,
but they want to make what they
consider to be an enhancement.
I could argue that both ways.
I really could.
What constitutes an enhancement?
And what do we allow?
What do we disallow?
Do we allow eye
color to be changed?
Do we allow height and
height to be changed?
Do we allow weight, projected
weight to be changed,
if there is a genetic
indicator that
indicates that this child
will likely be obese?
I mean, there's so much
subjectivity baked into this
that I actually
think we need to ask
the second, third, and
fourth question here, and not
be a solution in
search of a problem.
So while my wife and I might
make choices to not gene
edit a child in
utero, I'm not yet
ready to concede the point that
anything beyond addressing what
we know to be malignancies
in our genetic profile
is necessarily a bad thing.
I tend to be in favor of more
freedom than less freedom.
JARED COHEN: So speaking
of less freedom, let's talk
about China for a minute.
Because you mentioned it before.
So China, in many respects,
is a fascinating case study
for a lot of the things that
you mentioned in the book,
and how will it play out.
Let me ask you two different
China question, one about
innovation, one about
the increased complexity
of geopolitics, and then
maybe a leadership question,
and then I'll open it
up to the audience.
So when I look at China,
they are competing
in two capitalist systems.
They compete in one
capitalist system, that
allows them to innovate by
stealing intellectual property,
and then scaling
coffee companies
on the foundation of that
stolen intellectual property.
And then they also compete
in the same capitalist system
that the United States is
part of, which is basically
legitimate innovation.
And they're able to do both.
There's a lot of legitimate
innovation in China,
and then, of course,
there's some stolen
intellectual property.
So there's an asymmetry here.
And in a world where China
can play in two systems,
and innovate in
ways that countries
that abide by different
sets of norms and laws
can't, it doesn't seem
to me like a fair fight.
So how does that
play out in terms
of the competition over
building the next innovative,
multi-billion dollar company?
ALEC ROSS: So this is going
to be terrible undiplomatic,
but I'm not a diplomat
anymore, so I don't care.
I actually would
argue against-- I
mean, what innovation
has come from China
that's rooted in the internet?
Not a lot.
I mean, you'd be hard pressed.
And most of it is derivative.
It's a little tweak here.
It's a little tweak there.
I actually think that,
overwhelmingly, China
has built big
internet businesses
because it has stolen
intellectual property
from abroad.
When I was in government,
we declassified
a National Intelligence Estimate
report, which we really did,
which pegged the annual
intellectual theft
about $300 billion a year.
I mean, if you go into
the source code of Renren,
it says "A Mark Zuckerberg
Production" on it.
Literally.
Because Mark did a vanity
thing in the source code
for Facebook, and they stole it.
We literally saw it in Renren.
It's hilarious.
So I actually think
that while they
have built some good
internet based businesses,
I think they're largely
a product of theft
than mercantilism.
And so the question now is
the industries of the future.
Will they be able to
innovate in fields
like the commercialization
of genomics, big data, cyber
security, and other such fields.
And I think the
answer is, yes and no.
I think that there
will be fields
where they create things, where
imagination and invention turns
to commercialization, and they
build legitimate businesses.
I think there will be
fields where they do that.
I think that the
commercialization of genomics
is likely to be an especially
good place for them.
BGI, what was formerly called
the Beijing Genomics Institute,
is now actually the largest.
It does more gene sequencing
than any place on planet Earth.
And in genomics, for
example, unlike the internet,
where they built their
internet based businesses,
being content from
the outset to wall off
their population of
1.3 billion people,
so long as they
could dominate China,
they didn't mind that they
were not largely exporting.
It aws really Jack
Ma and Ali Baba
who first asserted that Chinese
companies can and should
export.
And as Ali Baba, on the
consumer facing side,
it was walled away on
the enterprise side.
And now we see with
Xiaomi and others,
they are growing more assertive.
What do you think is that for
the industries of the future,
I don't think that
they're going to be
content to view their own home
market as an end unto itself
initially.
And I think they're going to
be more inherently global.
And as a result of
that, I actually
think that they will be
more rights respecting.
In the commercialization
of genomics,
for example, I would
be very surprised
if BGI, or any of the
other large institutions,
get into the pattern of IP theft
and state supported IP theft,
that their internet-based
businesses did.
And I think that that is largely
because of if they position
themselves in the
marketplace like that,
then they will have a
very difficult time doing
the necessary partnering
and other exercises
it will take to eventually
become the deca-billion billion
company HQed in China.
So as much as I bashed China on
their practices in the internet
space, and-- full disclosure,
my name was a banned search term
on the internet in
China for two years,
and I spent $100 million of
taxpayer dollars on different
technologies to allow people
to get around government
firewalls, most of which
you've probably used-- I--
JARED COHEN: I do think that
would get your name banned.
That would do it.
ALEC ROSS: Yeah.
I do think that I take a more
optimistic view of the future,
because I do think that
the entrepreneurs in China
are thinking globally now
as opposed to locally,
the way that their
internet-based businesses did,
beginning the late '90s until
three, four, five years ago.
JARED COHEN: We've
talked about this before.
There's also, especially
with the younger generation
of entrepreneurs,
there's a badge
of honor associated
with being able to say
they did it legitimately.
Let me ask you a
geopolitical question
about China, then one quick
one on leadership/parenting.
And then we'll open it up.
One of the things you
talk about is the impact
that all of these innovation
industries of the future
will have on just the
International dynamics that we
see play out in geopolitics.
So last time I checked, there
was one international system.
It has a physical front,
and it has a digital front.
Yet when you look at the
foreign policies of states,
their policies in
one domain, at times,
will contradict the other.
So let me give an example,
in the context of the US
and China.
What is the relationship between
the United States and China?
Well, in the physical
domain, at worst,
it's frenemies, at
best, it's partners.
In the digital domain,
the two countries
are in a perpetual state of
war, and the relationship
is more kinetic and adversarial
than the physical one
between the United
States and North Korea.
So the problem I have is these
are still only two countries.
Their foreign policies
contradict each other
across the two domains.
So is there are a point at which
nefarious cyber activity spills
over and potentially fuels
a physical world conflict?
ALEC ROSS: Yes.
So we were talking earlier
about norm setting.
What's interesting
about the cyber domain
is there essentially are no
norms that have been set.
There are very few things
in the ways of treaties.
There are very few
multilateral institutions
that are functional.
It's not like the frameworks
that were built in the '50s
through the '80s around
nuclear arms, which
we were able to forge agreements
with the USSR in large part
because of mutual interest.
Right now, the United States
and China, for example,
have such a different
set of values
around what it is
and is not permitted
in the internet space.
So the United States,
for example, we
will not give any ground
on, and we will not
be party to any treaty that
curtails our ability to engage
in intelligence activities.
We won't.
We won't be a signatory
to any of that.
And because we won't be a
signatory to any of that, which
is a precondition
for the Chinese
to engage with us on
anything, the Chinese
will not be a signatory to
anything meaningful that
curtails their work in
economic espionage, IP theft.
And so what you get is,
in the Venn diagram,
there is very little
overlapping space.
And what happens
is we end up having
a very different relationship
in the internet space,
in the cyber domain, than
we do in the physical world,
in the polite world.
What I will say, though, is
we're talking governments.
What would actually
be interesting to me
is the relationship not
just country to country,
but country to company.
So I remember, for example,
when Google was cyber attacked
in 2010, I think it was.
I think it was 2000-- maybe
it's the end of 2009, 2009.
And your then-CEO, Eric
Schmidt, picked up the phone
and called us, and described
to us what had happened.
Google was one of 35
large enterprises,
like Raytheon,
Boeing, and others,
that had been significantly
cyber attacked by the Chinese.
And so what was
interesting to me
is, these companies were large
and well established companies,
that, after being cyber
attacked, what they did
is they picked up the phone
and they called Washington.
But I imagine, what if it
was, instead of Eric Schmidt,
CEO of Google, what if
it was a 28 year-old who
had absolutely no interest
in what Washington
thought about any of this.
And after being
attacked, and after,
say, identifying the
point of attack coming
from unit 63198 of the People's
Liberation Army of China,
and you were able to identify
the very specific facilities
in the [? Bhutan ?]
district of Shanghai that
was the point of
origin of the attack,
instead of picking up the
phone and calling Washington,
what if they said,
let's take them out?
And so what's really
interesting, to me,
is the idea that the
conflict doesn't just
have to be country to country.
It could actually be
country to company,
and company to country.
And so Sony, for example,
after Sony was attacked,
now, Sony has absolutely
no cyber chops,
so they could not have fought
back against the North Koreans,
but what if they did?
And what if, instead
of after having
been hacked, what if they
had said, you know what?
We're now going to go after them
to the maximum extent possible?
So I also think
that companies play
an increasingly consequential
role in all this [INAUDIBLE].
JARED COHEN: And of course,
not every private sector
is the same.
In this country, you have the
private sector as distinct
from the public sector.
In some countries, it's
an arm of the state.
In other countries, it's
a mixture of the two
and more complex.
Last question before we open it
up, and we'll be brief on this,
but I think it's
relevant to everyone
here-- as somebody who's
worked at the highest
level in the public
sector, who's
studied all the industries
that are going to fundamentally
alter our world, you look
out at the audience here,
and you have the most
brilliant minds, in my opinion,
in the entire world,
people that are actually
building the things
that are going
to shape our future,
president, and going forward,
there's also an activist spirit
that we have at this company.
So what is the role of a
Google employee, for instance,
going forward?
How should we all, beyond
the day jobs that we have,
how should we be thinking
about our contributions
to the industries of the future?
ALEC ROSS: That's
really interesting.
That's a really
interesting question.
I'd say first, I'm really glad
that Google is doing things
like actually establishing
a company called Jigsaw,
and to actually be
able to organize
its activities in this space.
So I think that's and
a great first step
that many companies
are not taking,
in part, because they don't have
the capabilities that you do.
I would say two other things.
I would say, first of
all, don't rule out
the possibility of going to work
in government at some point.
Government, there are
aspects of government
that would infuriate
you, but you
get to work on incredibly
consequential stuff.
And there are certain
things that you simply
can't do as Google employees.
You cannot wipe out GPS in Syria
to prevent surgical political
assassinations because of the
collaboration between Syriatel
and the Syrian
intelligence services.
JARED COHEN: Maybe
[INAUDIBLE] can.
ALEC ROSS: Well, but if he
did, he'd be breaking the law.
Actually, in our country.
So I would actually
encourage you all
to think about public service.
For those of you that are happy
with your lives at Google,
and I think, certainly
just walking around here,
you ought to be, the other
thing that I would say
is, think about,
with your 20% time,
as well as with your
life outside of work,
how you can take the
skills that you have
and put it to work on
those public policy issues
that you care.
There's a huge amount of
asymmetry between civil society
and, say, this room full
of employees at Google.
Civil society,
non-profits, for example,
thirsts for the kind
of skills that you have
that they simply can't hire.
So to the extent that you can
use whatever time you have here
as well as outside of work
to meaningfully contribute
to public policy issues,
I think you're going
to find it quite rewarding.
JARED COHEN: Let's
take some questions.
Just wave your hand.
There's microphones here.
You can test your
vocal chops and scream
or you can go up
to the microphone.
I think you're supposed to
go to the microphone because
of the video.
I see you nodding.
And just introduce
yourself as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's--
JARED COHEN: You're good.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you can hear?
ALEC ROSS: You need to
to turn on the thing.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Hi.
My name is Donny Greenberg.
I'm new here.
I'm just wondering.
I think that a lot of what
you're talking about in terms
of, like, the last 50 years is
a story of global homogeneity,
just rights and norms becoming
more homogeneous as barriers
break down, people
have exposure to ideals
that they might not
have heard before.
And then you talk
about genomics,
and you talk about
how countries are
going to have very different
perspectives on what's allowed.
Do you think that going
forward, the story
becomes more heterogeneous
as people build up walls
to support their positions with
respect to what's OK ethically?
Or do you think it
becomes more homogeneous
as the barrier, the force of the
people pushes down those walls?
Thank you.
ALEC ROSS: So I think that
there are two things that
are going to happen.
Let's go back to
Papua New Guinea.
So I think that as a frontier
economies are brought
into the economic mainstream,
and in the global markets, what
we will see is a process of
homogenization, which is not
to say that Papua New
Guinea is suddenly
going to look like South Korea.
It's not.
But what you are going
to see is it is going
to tilt toward homogeneity.
The question about
heterogeneity is really, for me,
one about competition.
Is it going to be a
Chinese set of norms,
an American set of norms,
a European set of norms,
something else?
And so here, I think that we're
going to see more fragmentation
, but I don't know that I
would call it walling off.
I'd rather see it as
competition, and largely
a competition for wealth, and
geopolitical and geoeconomic
dominance.
So when a state or
society is making
a choice about the
degree to which it's
going to be open or closed,
permissive or restrictive,
or other such things,
at the end of the day,
they're trying to maximize for
one of two things- geopolitical
power or geoeconomic power.
And how that makes it
distinct, or heterogeneous
to use your word,
or looking more
like what exists across
the ocean, homogeneous,
I think will be
also of a question
on the part of the
entrepreneurial models, which
are not necessarily
going to in the state.
So there's a chapter in the
book called the geography
of future markets.
And one of the
things that I posit
is that as much of the trillions
of dollars of wealth creation
that have taken place in the
last 25 years with the internet
has flowed through
a 30 mile long,
15 mile wide area of California
called Silicon Valley.
I think that Silicon Valley
will remain strong, maybe even
strongest, in the next
wave of innovation,
but what I do posit is
that there will probably
be between 12 and 15
global foci, through 12
to 15 other places
around the world, which
will be significant centers of
innovation and wealth creation.
But where they are will be-- I
think it will be interesting.
They won't
necessarily be defined
by the national character.
It will be certainly
be influenced by it,
but we think about cities
like Dubai, or Cape Town,
or Shanghai, or Seoul,
or Sao Paulo, certainly
their products are part
of the nation state,
but they're also
something fairly
distinct unto themselves.
And in my own travels, what
I've come to understand
is that I'm much more likely
to see one of my peers
in any one of
those cities than I
am to see them in my native
West Virginia or something
like that.
And so I do think that as much
as the character of the nation
state will inform
how things look,
I also think that there is
an entrepreneurial class that
moves around the
globe, that congregates
in certain kinds of places
and will create businesses
there, that doesn't
necessarily comport entirely
with the national character.
JARED COHEN: Other questions?
[INAUDIBLE] much.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm Dan.
So you've spoken very
compellingly about winners,
industries that are emerging,
but in the spirit of President
Trump, can you talk a
little bit about losers?
[LAUGHTER]
What are the issues of
the past that we may not
expect to diminish?
AUDIENCE: We almost
made it the full hour
without talking
about Donald Trump.
[LAUGHTER]
ALEC ROSS: Vulgar,
demented Donald Trump.
We're all in trouble if
he becomes president.
So when I think about winners
and losers, the binary I think
of, I think the principal
political and economic binary
of the 20th century
was left versus right.
I think the dominant
political and economic binary
of the 21st century
is open versus closed.
And by open, what do I mean?
I mean is upward social and
economic mobility confined
to elites?
Or can public school
kids from West Virginia
make their way upward?
Are our cultural and religious
norms dictated from on high?
Or is it a rights
respecting country?
Religious, ethnic,
sexual minorities,
are women fully
empowered in the economy?
And recognizing that there
are no perfectly open
or closed societies,
the closest to either
might be North Korea being
closest to a closed society,
I think that that which
is going to most determine
who the winners are
and who the losers are,
is that I think that the
most open societies will
be those that are most
competitive in the industries
of the future.
Because going back
to my previous point
about the class of
entrepreneurs and innovators,
I see them increasingly want
to congregate and create
businesses and live and work
in the most open societies
possible.
I also think that these are
the places where capital flows
the most freely, where somebody
who dropped out of college
can get a significant seed
round and take their idea
and try to create a
product out of it.
I think it is the kind of place
where crazy ideas, and usually
a big business starts with a
crazy idea, where a crazy idea
actually gets a good chance.
So not thinking so
much about industries
that will be the quote
unquote losers of the future,
but when I think
about the places,
it will be those places that are
most closed, much more so than
during the last wave of
globalization, where the quote
unquote losers were
largely determined
by one of two factors-- what
are your relative labor costs,
and to what degree did you
adapt your economy from being
industrial to knowledge-based.
JARED COHEN: Other questions?
While we're waiting,
I have another.
Do you have one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JARED COHEN: OK.
And don't forget to
introduce yourself.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Yura.
And I'm very interested in what
you mentioned about robotics.
So I'm wondering
what you exactly
see in Japan about the
home care robotics,
and what is actually the
customer reaction to it?
And also, what do you think
about industrial robotics?
And do you see a
difference between the US
and these things that's
actually happening
in Japan our Asian countries?
ALEC ROSS: So let me
back up a little bit
and say that, I think that
the robots of the cartoon
and movies of the
1970s are going
to be the reality of the 2020s.
And I think that's largely going
to be because of two things--
first of all,
mapping belief space.
You know, the
mathematical breakthroughs
that have allowed us
to take historically
difficulty robotic
tasks like grasping
and make them more
programmable, and taking robots
from being dominantly two
dimensional beings to three
dimensional beings,
that and cloud robotics.
This is fundamentally changing
the economics of robotics.
So let's think about one
of the movies of the 1970s.
Let's think about--
AUDIENCE: Was anyone
here alive in the 1970s?
ALEC ROSS: Yeah, right?
they watched the movies
from the 1970s, Jared.
So let's think about C3PO.
If C3PO walked in here right
now and interrupted us,
he would say, oh dear, oh my!
And go find, choo-choo-choo,
an open seat right now.
And so what would be happening?
So what would be
happening, if you
think about the cognition
necessary for C3PO to recognize
that he had
interrupted a lecture?
Speaking, excusing himself,
the sensory ability
to identify an open
seat, and the mobility
to then be able to take a seat.
As a practical matter,
we know that he amount
of hardware and
software whirring
in that gold-plated body
would be consequential, right?
With cloud robotics, C3PO will
be a cloud-connected device.
So as he walks in and interrupts
us, he'll ping the cloud.
And the impact of this is one,
principally, of economics.
So I'm sure you're all
familiar with Foxconn.
Terry Gou, the CEO of Foxconn
explained the economics
of robotics to me.
He said humans are
little capex, a opex.
And robots are all
capex, no opex.
When you hire a human
being, maybe you
get a phone, or a computer,
business cards, not very much.
But every two weeks,
you want to get paid.
So very little upfront
cost, lots of opex.
By contrast, with robots
you have to buy the robot.
You have to buy the
expensive robot.
But once you do, you can
work him for 24 hours.
You don't have to
pay him a salary.
He's not going to get sick.
He's not going to unionize.
And so very little opex.
And so what's interesting
with cloud robots
is we're seeing new
equilibrium points
in the tradeoff between whether
it's worth hiring a human
or buying a robot.
And to your question
about the home care robots
in Japan, what we're seeing,
because of these two things,
mapping belief space
and cloud robotics,
we're seeing robots being
able to act in a whole nother
level of sophistication that was
largely unimaginable just three
years ago.
And so this has facilitated
their entry into the home.
And even though
it's not being done
on a very significant scale yet,
it's largely being accepted.
And I think it's largely
being accepted, in part,
because those who are actually
allowing for elder care robots
to be brought into their home
are doing so voluntarily.
Right?
It's not being imposed on them.
They're the early adopters.
And also, because, again,
going back to cultural norms.
There isn't the cultural
headwind that says,
you really shouldn't let your
grandmother be picked up out
of bed by a robot.
On to the question of how this
relates to industrial robots,
here too, it's
really interesting.
Out of the 196 countries
on planet Earth,
there are basically
only five that
matter in robot production, both
consumer and industrial robot
production-- the United
States, Germany, Japan,
South Korea, and China.
Those five countries are
the only ones that matter.
South Korea, a country
of 50 million people,
produces more industrial robots
then the 3 billion people that
live in India, Russia,
Africa, South America,
Central America combined.
What's interesting with
industrial robotics
is the move here is it's taking
robotic labor and automation
from doing work that is merely
manual and routine to cognitive
and non-routine.
So if you think about it, the
industrial robots of the past,
it largely displaced
the work of men
with big, strong shoulders
working in ports, factories,
mills, and mines.
Move object A to object
B. An industrial robot who
can move bigger projects,
do it more reliably,
and with less liability.
So what's interesting
now is, again,
because of AI, with
industrial robots being
able to view things
with more cognition,
and being able to do tasks
that are non-routine,
we're seeing new forms
of labor displacement,
and we're seeing new kinds
of industrial processes
that I think are
really interesting.
And the vast majority of it
is coming from South Korea
and Japan right now.
JARED COHEN: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Andrew.
You mentioned labor
displacement there at the end.
And you talk about these
dystopian and utopian futures,
and you also mentioned
that you don't
look more than 20 years ahead,
or else it just gets silly.
Do we see a basic income being
required in the next 20 years?
Or is that still too
silly to consider?
ALEC ROSS: No, I don't think
it's too silly to consider.
What's interesting
is I'm now asked
about a universal basic income
in pretty much every book
talk I do.
But this is a product
of the last six months.
If I had done this
six months ago,
I might have gotten
one question about it.
So this is something
that I think
there is an increasing public
recognition around this issue
of labor displacement.
Well, first of all,
we ought to recognize
that lots of countries
are already doing this.
Lots of places.
We know the example of
Scandinavian countries,
but I think that there will
be other places, especially
with high per capita
GDPs, which can basically
create welfare systems
without it being
too big a drag on the economy.
The problem in
the United States,
why I don't see it happening
over the next 10 years,
is because a universal
basic income would be
a massive entitlement program.
and as long as we are running
the kinds of budget deficits
that we are, it's not realistic.
We would have to
fundamentally change programs
like Medicare, Medicaid,
or our defense spending,
to be able to afford a UBI,
a universal basic income.
The other thing that makes me
think that the United States is
going to be ready for
it in the next 10 years
is because if you look at the
last entitlement program that
was just expanded,
Obamacare, I mean,
you would have thought we
burned the country down,
the kind of reaction
that it got.
And the establishment of
a universal basic income
would be far bigger
than Obamacare.
The last thing that
I think, presents
a real headwind for the
idea of the establishment
of a universal basic
income in the United States
is we tend to be a more
individualist society
than a collectivist society.
So the collectivist societies
are dominantly European
and have set up UBIs, have
a very different character
than most of America, which
is fiercely individualistic.
And I think that,
interestingly, a lot
of the opposition for a
universal basic income
would actually come from
the segments of society that
actually might be
its beneficiary.
So in my native West
Virginia, nobody
is more vulnerable
to be permanently
outside of the economic
mainstream than working class
West Virginians.
Yet they will vote against
their economic interests
because the perception will
be that somebody else will
be taking advantage,
that it will be unfair.
And these are the
people who are going
to be voting against
their economic interests
when they vote for Donald Trump.
JARED COHEN: Let me take the
liberty, as the moderator
to ask one final question
before we wrap up, which is,
there's a lot I want to ask you
about, from cryptocurrencies
to urbanization, and so forth.
But I want to ask you a
question about the one topic
that is heavily
pronounced in your book
that we haven't
discussed yet, which
is the last chapter,
which is called
"the most important
job you'll ever have,
the future of parenting."
I said at the
beginning that what
makes this book so interesting
is the methodology that Alec
used to write it.
And he literally traveled
around, asking generals,
and admirals, and
presidents of countries,
and dissidents, and
people from this country
and that country,
geneticists, et cetera,
all the same question
about what makes
a good parent in the future.
What types of issues
and challenges
will a parent have to
contend with in the future?
So what does parenting
look like in the future?
And what it is the wackiest
most complex thing that we'll
have to deal with as a parent?
ALEC ROSS: So first
of all, I don't
pretend to be a parenting
guru in the book.
My children would be
the first point out
I should be pretending
to be a parenting guru.
But what I did do is, everybody
who's really impressive, whom
I interviewed for the book
on their domain expertise,
I put these questions
about parenting to them.
And there were a couple of
interesting points of consensus
that emerged.
The first is the importance of
inter-disciplinary learning.
So people always say STEM, STEM,
STEM, STEM, STEM, STEM, STEM.
And yes, science, technology,
engineering, and mathematics
are very important.
But the indication that
I got is that the people
who will not just be
employed in the future,
but who will actually
be leaders in the future
will be those who are
able to combine levels
of scientific or
technological literacy
with aptitudes that
we think of as being
in the humanities, like
behavioral psychology,
economics, communications,
and other such things.
So being able to break down
the silos between, say computer
science and political
science, the people
who really break
down those barriers,
as you've done in
your career, Jared,
are really going to be
important leaders of the future.
The second thing that I would
say, the anti for tomorrow
is in many respects, I
think, going to be languages.
Computer languages
and foreign languages.
Absent our having
the device in our ear
that understands everything
that everybody is telling us,
I do think that getting
good old fashioned ink
stamps in your passport is
going to be increasingly
necessary if you're going to be
a leader in tomorrow's economy.
As our economy grows more
interconnected, people
who are willing and able to move
around to frontier economies
and be a part of the
growth of, say, Papua New
Guinea in the same way
in which people were
a part of the growth of
China beginning 15 years ago,
that's really where a lot of
the great fortunes will be made.
What are they the
craziest challenges?
I think a lot of
it goes to privacy.
I am one of those people who
believes that privacy as we
traditionally know it is
gone and not coming back.
Today, March of 2016, we live
in a world of about 16 billion
internet-connected devices.
By 2020, that's going
to be 40 billion.
And so in a world of 40 billion
internet-connected devices,
which will probably be creating
about 20 zetabytes of data
every year, the kind
of transparency,
not from surveillance so
much as from sousveillance,
I think is going to create a
digital profile for everybody.
And I think that the real norm
shifting is that everybody's
going to have a scandal.
And I think that in a world
where all of our lives
are consistently
documented, I think
that the norms that are
going to shift, I think
is we're going to increasingly
accept human fallibility.
The kinds of things
that JFK did,
we know, today would
never remain private,
would never remain secret.
But as more of our lives
become less secret,
instead of our
summarily condemning
more and more people,
I think we're going
grow more and more accepting.
I think about a corrupt use of
the presidency, for example.
In 1992, it was a legitimate
political issue did.
Bill Clinton inhale?
Did he take a drag on a joint?
And this was a question.
If he inhaled, is he
fit to be president?
Fast forward 16 years, Barack
Obama's running for president.
He's like, oh, I inhaled.
I inhaled a lot, and I liked it.
And oh, by the way, I did coke.
Non-issue.
Think about homosexuality.
I mean, when I was in college
20 something years ago,
homosexuality was
still this thing
that was considered aberrant
and almost scandalous.
There's the gay guy.
Whereas on university
campuses today,
we accept that there's a
fairly significant percentage
of everybody who's going
to be homosexual, right?
What happened?
Norms shifted.
And so I really think
that the big change is
going to be, like for
example with my kids, 9, 11,
and 13 years-old, as they grow
older in a world with so much
more transparency and so
much digital documentation,
I think that there's going to
be less privacy of the type
that we now know it.
And as a result of that, we are
going to increasingly accept
human fallibility.
JARED COHEN: Well, Alec, you've
written a brilliant book.
I'm almost impressed that Papua
New Guinea got three shoutouts
in the span of an hour.
That's more than probably they
ever get throughout history.
This book's exceptional.
And even more than the
ambition of the project,
and the breadth
of the interviews,
and the places that you
went to write this book,
is your masterful translation
of very complex topics
to audiences that will find
it interesting from the most
technical to the
least technical.
You've written a really
truly accessible book
and a brilliant book.
It's called "Industries
of the Future."
You all have free copies.
Go buy some for your friends.
Alec Ross, thank you very much.
ALEC ROSS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]